hey everyone i'm john coogan and welcome
to my guide to startup fundraising
last week i talked about closing a deal
and went into some details about the
safe
today i want to talk about what happens
when you close your round and start to
plan for the next one if you're
following my advice from the last video
then you're probably raising with
standard post money safes that have a
valuation cap and no discount
but fundraising is a messy process and
even though you might have a few angel
investors already committed on those
terms a larger investor could come along
and want to do a priced round so what
happens then
as we've mentioned before your goal as a
founder is to build a great business
and that means making your customers
happy growing your customer base
significantly every month
and finding a large market you can't
focus on any of that if you're tied up
in fundraising negotiations for months
at a time
that's why so much work has been done by
the startup community to simplify
fundraising
raising a priced round means you will
actually be issuing shares to the
investor
as opposed to signing an agreement to
give them shares in the future
because shares are actually changing
hands a price round is usually more
complicated than using safes
but that doesn't mean it's worth walking
away from a great investor just because
they want to do a priced round
let's go through some of the pros and
the cons of both the safe and the price
round
first is speed if you're using a
standard safe like the one on y
combinator's documents page
you can execute it in a single day using
an e-signature service like docusign
these documents have been used thousands
of times and there's nothing to
negotiate except for the valuation cap
with a priced round the closing process
usually takes at least a few weeks
which could be distracting if you're in
a particularly hectic period of growth
the second is cost since you don't need
a lawyer to review it
the safe essentially costs nothing to
execute priced rounds not only require
you to have your lawyer review documents
and manage a closing process
often you will be required to pay for
the legal costs of the lead investor
this can be as low as 5k
or as high as 60k a good rule of thumb
though
is to multiply whatever the investor is
asking for in legal reimbursement by
three since you will likely need to do
more legal work on your end to close the
deal
the third is terms price rounds have
very different expectations about what
terms are included by default
it's common for priced rounds to have
founder vesting requirements
board seats block rights and lots of
other items that will need to be
negotiated line by line
to be fair all of these items can be
included in safe side letters or
excluded from priced round documents but
the default state here matters
it's easier to ask an investor not to
add a side letter to a safe
than to ask that investor to remove an
item from a priced round term sheet
lastly there is sequencing because safes
can be executed individually
you can close the first investor very
early and avoid a situation where an
investor is soft committed
but waiting for you to get a lead
investor before they sign documents or
wire any money
additionally it's not uncommon for the
announcement of a fundraising round
to attract more investors and it's
harder to capitalize on those when
you've already closed a priced round
with safes you can always just issue one
more safe to get that investor in
this is a double-edged sword though on
the one hand it can be great to roll
your fundraising from 100k to 1 million
as you gain heat on your round
but on the other hand having safes at
different valuation caps can make
tracking your total dilution very
difficult
being overwhelmed by complicated safes
is so common that it even has a nickname
the waterfall to put it simply the
waterfall is a situation where the
founder loses control of the round
by issuing dozens of safes at increasing
valuations
no single safe in this case causes
massive dilution but taking together
they can add up to 30 or more percent of
the company
it's essentially a death by a thousand
cuts
in 2017 pascal levinson and andrew crown
published an article
on the waterfall effect in techcrunch
and while it does a good job of warning
entrepreneurs about the risk of early
stage dilution
i think it wrongly targets the safe
since the waterfall effect can also
occur
when founders use convertible notes fear
of the waterfall alone
isn't enough of a reason in my mind to
abandon safes entirely
but if you do want to do a priced round
here's my advice
try and use standard documents from
siriseed.com whenever possible
they're simpler than what you would be
using if you did a series a
and it's much cheaper and quicker to
execute second
make sure you understand what provisions
are included in the docs that you're
signing
there are generally two types of
provisions in a financing document
financial provisions and control
provisions financial provisions govern a
few things
mainly who owns the financial interest
in the company whether or not they have
the right to buy more shares in the
future
and what protections they have if the
company sells or goes bankrupt
control provisions are all about who
runs the board of directors
who can hire and fire the executives and
who makes the final decisions on big
company issues
if you look around the technology
industry you will notice that many
companies have special provisions where
the founders control the company
even though they don't own 51 percent or
more of the financial interest in the
business anymore
whether you care more about financial
provisions or control provisions
will depend on your personal life goals
but if you really want to understand
deal structures and the associated
trade-offs
i recommend reading venture deals by
brad feld and jason mendelsohn which
i've linked below
regardless of the exact investment
vehicle you use once you close the deal
it's your job to get back to building
but things will be different in a few
key ways
you'll need to send regular updates to
your investors and hold board meetings
even if the founders are the only board
members
since investors expect further growth
you need to start solidifying your key
performance indicators or kpis
and start thinking about what milestones
you want to hit before your next round
when it comes to investor updates the
key to success is focusing on a single
consistent metric
like active users or revenue and
committing to a cadence
with everything else going on at your
startup on a daily basis it can be
really easy to let these updates slip
so create a schedule that you can stick
to consistently
aside from your kpis you'll also want to
include information about important
product milestones
new customer wins key hires and any asks
you have for the investors
investor updates are a great way to get
your investors to add value and help you
make connections that they wouldn't have
thought of otherwise
running an effective board meeting could
be the subject of an entire video
but in short you should figure out what
topics you want to discuss
then build a board deck circulate it
beforehand to everyone who's going to
attend
and then make sure to present the
decisions that were made at the meeting
to the rest of the team so everyone
stays aligned
in terms of your series a milestone you
will need to forecast your primary kpi
out roughly 12 to 18 months to figure
out what growth rate you need
to hit that goal if you're tracking
monthly revenue your investors should be
able to help you understand what monthly
revenue numbers they are typically
seeing at series a for your sector
as well as how fast that number should
be growing once you have that milestone
in mind
it's your responsibility to deploy the
funds you raise judiciously
raising a series a will always be
significantly harder than raising a seed
round
so you need to plan for profitability
never assume that you will be able to
raise more money
no matter how easy the last round was
avoid letting your expenses spike and
focus on letting growth justify hiring
it's common for investors to recommend
hiring fast and in some cases that is
the best strategy
but you need to make sure that the new
hires will justify the added costs
investors often overemphasize hiring
quickly
this is because as investors they're
used to deploying capital to solve
problems
and encouraging overspending to a small
degree
will lead to bigger future rounds where
they can buy a larger share of the
company
just make sure that you have a solid
financial plan and can get to
profitability if need be
the market can shift at the drop of a
hat and you need to be able to react
quickly to stay alive
even though i've now published nearly a
full hour of content on fundraising
it's important to try and keep it as
simple as possible
things can get complicated quickly and
that will drain the energy you need to
build a great business
the easiest way to keep things simple is
to use the fundraising best practices
outlined here
and try and push back on any
complications that are introduced by
investors
ultimately fundraising is a game of give
and take understanding the trade-offs
between different investors
documents and terms will give you the
ability to close your round quickly and
focus on building a great business
if you enjoyed this video or this series
please consider subscribing to the
channel for more content
and if you have any questions just leave
me a comment below i'm definitely
reading them
thanks for watching